And listen, I'm a modern woman.
I am totally down with splitting the bill.
But then Steve the I.T. guy didn't come back.
(Gasping)
And that was my entire month's rent.
(Audience gasps)
So needless to say, I was not having a good night.
So I run home, I call my mother, I call my sister,
and as I do, at the end of each one of these terrible, terrible dates,
I regale them with the details.
And they say to me,
"Stop complaining."
(Laughter)
"You're just being too picky."
So I said, fine, from here on out I'm only going on dates
where I know there's Wi-Fi, and I'm bringing my laptop.
I'm going to shove it into my bag,
I'm going to have this email template,
and I'm going to fill it out and collect information
on all these different data points during the date
to prove to everybody that empirically,
these dates really are terrible.
(Laughter)
So I started tracking things like really stupid, awkward, sexual remarks;
bad vocabulary;
the number of times a man forced me to high-five him.
(Laughter)
So I started to crunch some numbers,
and that allowed me to make some correlations.
So as it turns out,
for some reason, men who drink Scotch reference kinky sex immediately.
(Laughter)
Well, it turns out that these probably weren't bad guys.
There were just bad for me.
And as it happens, the algorithms that were setting us up,
they weren't bad either.
These algorithms were doing exactly what they were designed to do,
which was to take our user-generated information,
in my case, my résumé,
and match it up with other people's information.
See, the real problem here is that,
while the algorithms work just fine,
you and I don't,
when confronted with blank windows
where we're supposed to input our information online.
Very few of us have the ability
to be totally and brutally honest with ourselves.
The other problem is that these websites are asking us
questions like, are you a dog person or a cat person?
Do you like horror films or romance films?
I'm not looking for a pen pal.
I'm looking for a husband. Right?
So there's a certain amount of superficiality in that data.
So I said fine, I've got a new plan.
I'm going to keep using these online dating sites,
but I'm going to treat them as databases,
and rather than waiting for an algorithm to set me up,
I think I'm going to try reverse-engineering this entire system.
So knowing that there was superficial data
that was being used to match me up with other people,
I decided instead to ask my own questions.
What was every single possible thing
that I could think of that I was looking for in a mate?
So I started writing
and writing and writing,
and at the end, I had amassed 72 different data points.
I wanted somebody was Jew-ish,
so I was looking for somebody
who had the same background and thoughts on our culture,
but wasn't going to force me to go to shul every Friday and Saturday.
I wanted somebody who worked hard,
because work for me is extremely important,
but not too hard.
For me, the hobbies that I have
are really just new work projects that I've launched.
I also wanted somebody who not only wanted two children,
but was going to have the same attitude toward parenting that I do,
so somebody who was going to be totally okay
with forcing our child to start taking piano lessons at age three,
and also maybe computer science classes if we could wrangle it.
So things like that, but I also wanted somebody
who would go to far-flung, exotic places, like Petra, Jordan.
I also wanted somebody who would weigh 20 pounds more than me at all times,
regardless of what I weighed.
(Laughter)
So I now have these 72 different data points,
which, to be fair, is a lot.
So what I did was, I went through and I prioritized that list.
I broke it into a top tier and a second tier of points,
and I ranked everything starting at 100
and going all the way down to 91,
and listing things like I was looking for somebody who was really smart,
who would challenge and stimulate me,
and balancing that with a second tier and a second set of points.
These things were also important to me but not necessarily deal-breakers.
(Laughter)
So once I had all this done, I then built a scoring system,
because what I wanted to do was to sort of mathematically calculate
whether or not I thought the guy that I found online
would be a match with me.
I figured there would be a minimum of 700 points
before I would agree to email somebody or respond to an email message.
For 900 points, I'd agree to go out on a date,
and I wouldn't even consider any kind of relationship
before somebody had crossed the 1,500 point threshold.
Well, as it turns out, this worked pretty well.
So I go back online now.
I found Jewishdoc57
who's incredibly good-looking, incredibly well-spoken,
he had hiked Mt. Fuji,
he had walked along the Great Wall.
He likes to travel
as long as it doesn't involve a cruise ship.
And I thought,
I've done it!
I've cracked the code.
I have just found the Jewish Prince Charming
of my family's dreams.
There was only one problem:
He didn't like me back.
And I guess the one variable that I haven't considered
is the competition.
Who are all of the other women on these dating sites?
I found SmileyGirl1978.
She said she was a "Fun girl who is Happy and Outgoing."
She listed her job as "teacher."
She said she is "silly, nice and friendly."
She likes to make people laugh "alot."
At this moment I knew,
clicking profile after profile that looked like this,
that I needed to do some market research.
So I created 10 fake male profiles.
Now, before I lose all of you --
(Laughter) --
understand that I did this strictly to gather data
about everybody else in the system.
I didn't carry on crazy Catfish-style relationships with anybody.
I really was just scraping their data.
But I didn't want everybody's data.
I only wanted data on the women who were going to be attracted
to the type of man that I really, really wanted to marry.
When I released these men into the wild,
I did follow some rules.
So I didn't reach out to any woman first.
I just waited to see who these profiles were going to attract,
and mainly what I was looking at was two different data sets.
So I was looking at qualitative data,
so what was the humor, the tone,
the voice, the communication style
that these women shared in common?
And also quantitative data,
so what was the average length of their profile,
how much time was spent between messages?
What I was trying to get at here was that I figured, in person,
I would be just as competitive as a SmileyGirl1978.
I wanted to figure out how to maximize my own profile online.
Well, one month later,
I had a lot of data, and I was able to do another analysis.
And as it turns out, content matters a lot.
So smart people tend to write a lot --
3,000, 4,000, 5,000 words about themselves,
which may all be very, very interesting.
The challenge here, though, is that the popular men and women
are sticking to 97 words on average
that are written very, very well,
even though it may not seem like it all the time.
The other hallmark of the people who do this well
is that they're using non-specific language.
So in my case,
"The English Patient" is my most favorite movie ever,
but it doesn't work to use that in a profile,
because that's a superficial data point,
and somebody may disagree
and decide they don't want to go out
because they didn't like sitting through the three-hour movie.
Also, optimistic language matters a lot.
So this is a word cloud
highlighting the most popular words that were used
by the most popular women,
words like "fun" and "girl" and "love."
And what I realized was not that I had to dumb down my own profile.
Remember, I'm somebody who said
that I speak fluent Japanese and I know JavaScript
and I was okay with that.
The difference is that it's about being more approachable
and helping people understand the best way to reach out to you.
And as it turns out, timing is also really, really important.
Just because you have access to somebody's mobile phone number
or their instant message account
and it's 2 o'clock in the morning and you happen to be awake,
doesn't mean that that's a good time to communicate with those people.
The popular women on these online sites
spend an average of 23 hours in between each communication.
And that's what we would normally do in the usual process of courtship.
And finally --
there were the photos.
All of the women who were popular showed some skin.
They all looked really great,
which turned out to be in sharp contrast
to what I had uploaded.
(Laughter)
Once I had all of this information,
I was able to create a super profile,
so it was still me,
but it was me optimized now for this ecosystem.
And as it turns out, I did a really good job.
I was the most popular person online.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And as it turns out, lots and lots of men wanted to date me.
So I call my mom, I call my sister, I call my grandmother.
I'm telling them about this fabulous news,
and they say, "This is wonderful! How soon are you going out?"
I said, "Actually, I'm not going to go out with anybody."
Because remember, in my scoring system,
they have to reach a minimum threshold of 700 points,
and none of them have done that.
They said, "What? You're still being too damn picky."
Well, not too long after that, I found this guy, Thevenin,
and he said that he was culturally Jewish,
he said that his job was an arctic baby seal hunter,
which I thought was very clever.
He talked in detail about travel.
He made a lot of really interesting cultural references.
He looked and talked exactly like what I wanted,
and immediately, he scored 850 points.
It was enough for a date.
Three weeks later, we met up in person
for what turned out to be a 14-hour-long conversation
that went from coffee shop to restaurant
to another coffee shop to another restaurant,
and when he dropped me back off at my house that night
I re-scored him --
[1,050 points!]
Thought, you know what,
this entire time, I haven't been picky enough.
Well, a year and a half after that,
we were non-cruise ship traveling
through Petra, Jordan,
when he got down on his knee and proposed.
A year after that, we were married,
and about a year and a half after that,
our daughter, Petra, was born.
Audience: Oh!
(Applause)
[What it means...]
Obviously, I'm having a fabulous life, so --
(Laughter)
The question is, what does all of this mean for you?
Well, as it turns out, there is an algorithm for love.
It's just not the ones that we're being presented with online.
In fact, it's something that you write yourself.
So whether you're looking for a husband or a wife
or you're trying to find your passion
or you're trying to start a business,
all you have to really do is figure out your own framework
and play by your own rules,
and feel free to be as picky as you want.
Well, on my wedding day,
I had a conversation again with my grandmother,
and she said, "All right, maybe I was wrong.
It looks like you did come up with a really, really great system.
Now, your matzah balls ...
They should be fluffy, not hard."
(Laughter)
And I'll take her advice on that.
(Applause)